(syringe squelching)
- Well, isn't that odd?
- (laughing) Okay!
We watched the medical dramas.
We played the games.
But now it's time to take
a look at one of the most
- Clear!
(electricity buzzing)
(Homer grunts)
- More.
- Why are these shocking everybody?
Even in the cartoons, they
take it from the medical dramas
and they're shocking everybody.
Chest compressions if
their heart has stopped
and they're not breathing.
And my man's going, "More. More."
- Well, we can't fix his heart,
but we can tell you
exactly how damaged it is.
- What an age we live in.
- It's classic in medicine
where we don't have all the solutions
and people right away started saying,
"Oh, medicine sucks. Well,
how come we don't have this?
"Maybe you're just a
doctor that doesn't know
"what the cure to this problem is."
No, the human body's very complex.
And while we know a lot about it,
there's still a lot more left to learn.
- Homer, this is a new
body fat analysis test.
I start you jiggling and measure
how long it takes to stop.
(belly squelching)
Caliper tests,
weightless pool tests
for body fat percentage,
punch in the guts test in "The Simpsons."
- Mr. Simpson,
I'm afraid you have a
crayon lodged in your brain.
- There's a crayon in my brain?
But I've had thousands of head X-rays.
How come no one ever noticed it before?
- I can answer that.
You see, whenever I picked up an X-ray,
I always hold it like this.
My thumb must have covered up the crayon.
- When you look at an X-ray,
you have to look at many things,
including the issue at hand.
So if a person has shortness of breath,
you wanna look at the lungs.
You also wanna look at
the surrounding structures
because the last thing you
wanna do is look at an X-ray
to see if the patient has a pneumonia
and missed the cancer that's
growing in their humerus,
or on their rib, or on their clavicle.
- This place seems even
nicer than the Mayo Clinic.
- Mayo Clinic, eh?
(gentle harp music)
- Should we slice them diagonally
or just cut off the crust?
- Aw!
Why is it called the Mayo Clinic?
It's gotta be because there was a doctor
that started with the last name Mayo.
It has nothing to do
with mayonnaise. (laughs)
- [Sam] Founders Charles and William Mayo.
- Look at that!
(cat purring)
Too wonderful.
(dramatic music)
(car locks slamming)
(car tires screeching)
(Dr. Hibbert laughing)
- It's shot day!
(children screaming)
- There's actually a really
adorable video of a doctor
who does this whole show
for kids with the needle
to get them excited about it.
And then fake injects himself
and then injects the child.
And then they don't even feel the pain
'cause there's so much going on.
For kids who are able to reason somewhat,
I try and talk to them
as if they're adults.
I bargain with them.
And I say, "I'm gonna give
you this really cool pillow."
And they're like, "Why do we want a pillow
"that looks like you?"
And I'm like, "True."
And I get them something else
that is furry and cute
and soft, like bear.
Or I give them stickers
of their favorite shows.
And they're like, "Oh, that's awesome.
"What are we doing today?"
I'm like, "Well, today your
gonna get a vaccine, a shot.
"Here's why," blah, blah, blah.
They're like, "Okay, that sounds fair.
"You gave me a sticker and a weird pillow.
"So you must be nice."
I give them a quick shot.
I'm very gentle. We're very good with it.
My nurses are amazing.
And then they leave happy.
"Hibbert Moneymaking Organization."
Is that what HMO stands
for this whole time?
- I can provide every medical
service you'll ever need
under one roof.
- Rub a palm-full of this medicated salve
into your scalp every half an hour.
Keep him away from open
flames and pregnant women.
- These should help those
fallen arches. Enjoy.
- Hmm, throat looks a little red.
I better spray it.
- (laughing) Oh, my God. This
is my favorite skit ever.
I think it has less to do with HMOs.
But in general, the fact
that people in our society
have grown up with this
theory inside their head,
that they need to see a specialist
in order to stay healthy,
and it's so not true.
Because specialists oftentimes
deal with really complex cases,
they treat things a little
bit more aggressively
than your family medicine or
your primary care doctor would.
Please don't think you
need to see a specialist
for everything because,
A, that will happen.
B, many things will go away on their own,
and you don't need to
spend a whole ton of money
to see a specialist in
order for that to happen.
And, C, your primary care doctor's
well versed in solving all these problems.
And not only are we well
versed in solving them,
we know you best 'cause we
have an existing relationship.
- Now, Doctor, I want you
to test me for everything.
Every disease on this chart.
- Fine, we'll just start
by drawing some blood.
(syringe squelching)
Well, isn't that odd?
- (laughing) Okay! I'm
gonna hit "Simpsons" hard
with the medical inaccuracies.
We do not stab patients with the syringe
and have it come out the
other side of their arm,
and be like, "Oh, I
guess it's not working."
We do not just check
for a bunch of diseases.
When you come in for a checkup,
part of that is figuring out
what diseases we can actually screen for.
There are some, like cancers.
What diseases we can prevent.
We could also look at what risks you face.
So get this, a patient comes
in, doesn't have liver disease,
but they talk to me honestly,
we have a good conversation
and finds out they're drinking
a bottle and a half of vodka a day.
It's a lot, but some people do do this.
We have a conversation about, A,
what can we do to prevent them
from drinking and driving?
What we can do for them,
preventing themselves causing harm
in other ways to themselves,
when they are inebriated.
How can we get them
to cut down the amount
that they're drinking
so they can stay healthier longer.
Look at how much I've
affected their lifespan,
the progression of disease,
simply by having a good conversation.
That's what you should
expect from a doctor
when you go in for a physical.
And if you get anything less than that,
please look for a second opinion.
- Mr. Burns, I'm afraid you are
the sickest man in the United States.
You have everything.
- You mean I have pneumonia?
- Yes.
- Juvenile diabetes?
- Hysterical pregnancy?
- A little bit. Yes.
You also have several diseases
that have just been discovered.
- First of all, how does
he have juvenile diabetes?
He's not of juvenile age.
(text dinging)
- This sounds like bad news.
- Well, you'd think so,
but all of your diseases
are in perfect balance.
Here's the door to your body. You see?
And these are oversized, novelty germs.
That's influenza, that's bronchitis,
and this cute little cuddle bug
is pancreatic cancer. (chuckles)
Here's what happens
when they all try to get
through the door at once.
(whooping) Move it, chowder head!
We call it Three Stooges Syndrome.
- No.
If you have a lot of diseases,
it's not better than having less diseases.
Also, if you're a good doctor
and a lot of tests come up positive,
you need to start looking for a cause
that perhaps ties in all
of these diseases together.
I don't just say, "Hey, you
got a bunch of diseases.
"Deuces."
- There's a crazy man
with a scalpel in ER!
He's demanding to see a quack!
(dramatic music)
(Abe yelling)
- Hi, everybody.
Now, tell Dr. Nick where is the trouble?
- I'm itchy! I got ants in my pants!
I'm discombobulated! Get me a calmative!
- Slow down, sir!
You're going to give
yourself skin failure.
- What is skin fail?
- I think skin failure is
when your skin just gives up
and starts sloughing off.
Steven Johnson Syndrome.
(text tinkling)
- [Instructor] Insert the
retractor and crank it
until the ribs swing open,
like a rusty drawbridge.
(body squelching)
Ah! No, blood!
- Silly, but truth to it.
We do watch videos on
procedures all the time.
And that's a good thing!
You want your doctor up to date
and seeing the procedure
before they do it.
Even if they've done it multiple times,
that little refresher
goes a long, long way.
And you know where we a lot of it?
YouTube.
Your doctor watches YouTube
before they perform surgeries on you.
That's the truth.
- [Dr. Nick] These gloves came
free with my toilet brush.
- Usually. you have someone
help you with the gloves,
have the package open
because remember the inside
of the package is sterile,
but the outside is not.
So there's a specific way
you have to put the gloves on
to make sure that you're keeping sterile.
(Homer breathing deeply)
(air hissing)
- [Dr. Nick] What the hell is that?
- That's something you don't
wanna hear from your surgeon.
That and, "Oops!"
- I know I'm supposed to cut
something, but what and where?
- The mask is not part
of the sterile field.
So if you make contact with your mask,
right away, you have to leave,
change gloves, re-scrub in,
and then do the whole
process all over again.
So my man is not sterile no more!
- Dr. Nick Riviera!
Remember me?
- Well, if it isn't my
old friend, Mr. McGreg!
With a leg for an arm
and an arm for a leg.
- The only question I have
after watching that is
what is that doctor's specialty?
Dr. Nick, what do you do?
"Simpsons," all in all,
does a great job of teaching you medicine.
Albeit satirically,
but as you've seen with The
Onion episodes in the past,
and my "Saturday Night
Live" medical skit reviews.
Which one are you clicking?
Which one are you enjoying?
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
(gentle upbeat music)